how does a young man from connecticut
book a role
in the amazing spider-man um well i had
been
in new york kind of doing the grind for
a couple years
um by that point and the woman who was
doing the
new york casting for the movie um
was the lady who did the original
casting for law and order
so she knew me from there and called me
in
and i actually just had one on tape
audition and i we we sent it in
she put like i went into the new york
casting director she put me on tape
and sent me uh to la for the producers
and mark to watch
and um i it was a month it was over a
month i think and i had just written it
off
and then like a day or two later
after i even told my roommate i was like
a month has gone by
it's not going to happen the next day i
got
a call um just saying i had booked it
off of the taped audition
so and then it was a couple months
before we filmed and
it was it was quite an experience yeah
and where did you film
so we originally filmed in um
in woodside queens where it actually
takes place
um and then we did reshoots in um
pasadena um so the
the interior of the scene is in new york
and the exterior of the scene is in
pasadena
so you had to fly back out to the
country yeah yeah they flew me out in
december
like we shot in april i believe in new
york
and then in december i flew out to do
reshoots
so i had to get hair extensions because
i i had very long hair in the movie
and i had gotten a haircut in the
meantime
and so when i came out they had to put
hair extensions to get it back to the
length
and it's crazy the the hair lady she
just walked over she was like
it's a 44 brown and just i was
they brought back extensions like two
minutes later that were
exactly my hair color it was it was
pretty amazing
and this was human hair do you know i
don't
know i didn't want to think about that
and so how long is the actual scene and
then how long did it take to
film it um i actually don't know exactly
when it comes
out to the full scene less than two
minutes i would say
is the full thing um you know you have
it on your reel
yeah yeah that's true and then oh
there's a little more than
is on my reel oh okay there's that's
probably about
half the scene that's on my reel um
and it took
i shot two days in new york one
one of those two days was actually a
scene like we shot my first day
and then i got called back because they
said mark had thought of a little
something to put at the end of the movie
in a montage so we shot that
and that got cut and then i got a
email to come out here in december and
that was one day
for 17 hours so i was on set a total of
three days probably 30 something hours
and then from when you taped that the
final pasadena
yeah shoot day how long before you
actually sat down and saw the film
the pasadena shoe was december of um
uh 2011 and the film came out
july 3rd 2012 and there was a
premiere that i got to go to the week
before that
oh nice yeah no in la i came out for
that oh wow
um it was oh i forget the name of the
theaters
but i got to like go and walk the red
carpet
and do some interviews and take some
pictures and all that it was very
felt very hollywood it was very fun um
it was it was a really cool experience
for the first time
i think if you watch if you watch andrew
garfield
on um i think it was e
uh news i'm just like walking around in
the background just looking around
because it's it's a little overwhelming
i had to walk down the first like
section of the red carpet was
um the photographers so it was like
three to five hundred photographers and
they they announce your name
so then everybody starts calling your
name and
you have to hit every camera with a good
look
you know michael over here over here it
was
it was a little uh crazy but very fun
um and then yeah there were of course
the big
entertainment news uh like
hollywood uh true hollywood
e true e true hollywood's no that's the
show e true hollywood story
right that's that's a little later yeah
yeah
and then there was like a bunch of uh um
new media interviews and stuff for blogs
and websites
right
you